[Applause]
[Music]
we did it
i never been so proud we broke the
record
on ksi subreddit the top voted
of all time
by far spent hours making this hope it's
worth turning powerful
award my firendart of ksi so beautiful
oh my yes yes
baby we did it
all of these awards mean nothing because
i have the turn here nope
how much money did i make for real uh
this is the best meme
has he reacted don't wait roll the intro
whatever i need to see
leave
[Music]
god damn it he hasn't seen yet then who
gave me the all-powerful
reward i'm rich dude all right how do i
how do i cash this out how do i get the
money 55 pounds that's all that's all i
got
i'm done all right let's review
therapist american pewdiepie
is not real he can't hurt you american
pewdiepie
damn i look kind of cute i like it
yeah shoot let's go out and bite
buy some beer and shoot some cows
hey fellow 19 year olds i need your help
i know this
isn't a meme and that is not that is a
big no-no but my wife and i are
celebrating our first anniversary
and i want to surprise her by making it
into the y are they married
yeah happy anniversary yeah
yeah you did it i bless your marriage
what do you want me to do it tamari your
marriage has been blessed
by many years infinite views
[Music]
there you go oh so you watch pewdiepie
name
every video
how how you doing
oh my god it never stops
[Music]
oh jesus christ dude
god like post
you know what i guess said tambourine
yes well done well done pink boy proud
of you
yeah it felix no yeah yeah we've seen
this already what
guess this all right which one was first
then uh which one which one said them
joke again but louder oh okay
it was the original swedes a thousand
years ago
now here it comes here comes there it is
swedes now yeah all right i found out
i'm not very threatening
sorry sorry i didn't know either it
doesn't feel good
god damn it oh my god marzia's
announcement
blows out porn we all know about my
creatives
oh my god edgar i now present you my
biggest creation yet
magic help actually i kind of want to
send this to her in case she hasn't seen
it because it's so good
what's up did you guys see marcia's
halloween outfit
absolutely terrifying she became her own
freakish creations who does this
it's really good though so creepy
marcia helped me with my outfit as well
as you can tell
by the perfect hair i'm pulling the rest
and iggy
god damn it we tried so hard with the
hair god damn it
it did not work at all it's such a good
outfit otherwise
i made the earrings the tag tub with the
hair how does paul never forget his hair
like that
huh it's impossible how how
how does he style his hair like that
[Music]
it is cute
he slapped he clapped but most
importantly
oh there it is edgar's nightmare be like
we tried to scare him with it but no he
wasn't scared
corpse voice corpse music of course
personality
yeah that sums it up pretty nicely
actually corpses cthulhu confirmed face
reveal
hey guys lord of darkness here richest
youtuber in the world
anastasia radzinskaya and who's that
dude perfect all right except split in
sex am i right
felix shellberg and felix sheldberg
i'm so happy for this
that i feel like shelby though he's it's
not as rich as me though
uh the name's so nice you say it twice
hell yeah
the mods put together a surprise
birthday which is submitted by the
community
but pewds never saw it a lot of people
what because it was never uploading
where is it hippies wish you a very
happy birthday
oh inspiration to me and i hope you have
a great birthday
thank you happy birthday beauty bye
hello
you and mom hey felix i just wanted to
wish you a happy birthday and tell you
that i really love your content and i
think
thank you thank you oh that's so sweet
hey i [ __ ] broke this left and right
happy birthday
thanks for making us smile these past 10
years oh
thank you hey pewt happy birthday
please don't tell me that's your wall oh
no thank you
yeah happy with the sciences
here's what you look like when i first
subscribed oh
i looked like oh whoa i was 11
i'm 20 now happy birthday dude that's
nuts
holy [ __ ] happy birthday felix thank you
thank you for everything
[Laughter]
oh thank you happy birthday felix from
your fellow swede
hell yeah happy birthday i've been
having this for a while now
nice thank you yeah that's old school
marge
thanks man goddamn
[Laughter]
i don't i can't pause this it's so good
i'll watch you all later i can't react
to the whole thing now
that's amazing thank you guys so much
that generally made me really happy
this looks like the original creator did
it
adopt no yes that's such a good idea
[Laughter]
okay so now if you see a child you're
gonna knock that
[Music]
hell yeah
that's so cute
[Music]
what a great idea
of my creations big brain big heart
tambourine
kiss well done well done
bank teller all right your last name the
bank
bt first robin so you're robbing the
yes i'm rubbing the bank can't you tell
by my face
i mean business you can buy arms for
your chicken
might see it
i think she's seen this already but i'll
send it to her anyway
oh my god this is so much whoa oh it's
okay it's not really
hell yeah that was amazing if marcel was
born in japan
[Applause]
anyone who wouldn't invest is a fool
true
peers mr b has made a statue of you in
this latest video
yeah i saw the video but i never saw the
snapchat for you i'm a heavy hitter hell
yeah
so you can call me hey congratulations
it's a celebration
that's so cool god damn i can't believe
i didn't even see it
well i wish i could have seen him
personally pewdies pie
nice or should i say no that's all i'm
gonna say
all right you made me make this felix
this is your fault
it's beautiful and some squidward kfci
is real
i knew it has he not reacted to it i'm
so bummed that
god damn it holy [ __ ] now that's a legit
halloween costume
hey fellow 19 year olds this is my
attempt at pewdiepie figurine attempt
you nailed it dude
even got the number well done that's
sick
amazing huge pee-pee love it i helped
pewdiepie win the subway
why would i kill him yeah he murdered me
and he i can't believe he used that as
an excuse
pewds yeah small creepy yeah i don't
[ __ ] around anymore
wait what is this oh my god
it's this leaked raw footage ah cassava
you post this
are you serious this is hypnotizing the
watch i like it
yeah damn the final scythe does a good
job editing
i gotta give it to him well done maybe
he deserve race
might say three men so that's why she
did it huh
it all makes sense man i want to give
you an award but i don't want to spend
money
felix chose an award which is made for
felix to give awards without spending
any money wait what
how how do i do this is that a troll no
it doesn't work
no hell no robber give me all your money
the weird kid oh my god
i'm finally getting attention robert
ah two seconds of a frame and i made fun
of i don't look good
mr peace talking to his millions of fans
on stream
mr b dude our reaction
our reaction when we both realized we
were imposter together
so good there were so many good memes
from me what the
[ __ ] okay
i'm getting screwed screw the giveaways
everyone be quiet so funny
peter and marcie are murderers i'm in
this fight for the spooky season and now
felix has a knife it took me three days
amazing
that's sick god damn it i can't believe
halloween is already over i was looking
forward to more spoopy season
but the biggest holiday of them all has
begun
no not no not november say it with me
i will not not oh i will not give in to
my physical cravings oh
i will break away from the eternal
recurrence oh
come on no not let's get it yeah nowhere
literally nowhere in japan
dick thunder meme still kicking it i
like it it even looks like a dick now i
like it
very nice my little sister has an
obsession with cutting the faces of baby
to jesus christ
why would you do that might see it
finally i heard the opponent
i better would be legendary
felix be like happy birthday to me
rakesh
please wish me a happy birthday make a
call come on
respect rakesh i'll call i'll text him
right now what's his name does anyone
have it's not rakesh number
uh making creative looking toys marzia
this came from
sorry might say sid from toy story
confirm i knew it
guys literally only want one thing and
it's flipping disgusting
pierce and mr peace i'm so glad i got it
with mr maze it was so fun
and we won crazy i just gotta get it
with uh
jack now and the circle is complete i
can finally never play the game again
wanted to draw something cute hope you
bros like it
that is very cute
[Laughter]
that's literally the next step isn't it
a full-blown
furry mecca corpse i'm gonna kill you
everyone's sipping on corpse oh yeah
kill me with your deep sexy voice corpse
where's the avatar one it was so funny i
watch avatar now phil
how do you do fella kids yeah i got the
reference
it was funny when october is about to
end but pierce hasn't done a meme review
and spoopy means i'm sorry
i guess we yeah i didn't see i can't
believe it's already over
it's all right we got no none it's all
good day two baby
biggest brain play biggest brain play
ever oh here it is
it's mr beast that didn't work
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
jimmy you pulled the subway car like
that
[Music]
uh why did that oh he looks actually sad
to see if you know what someone got
killed in the back
nobody
he knows i was joking come on
jurassic park franchise if you want to
make it historically accurate hit me up
next time
the problem with being sweet is that
we're the least threatening people of
all time
oh is this real i bought another
billboard approved
what that looks really central too what
the [ __ ]
oh this is an actual thing people
actually buying villa just for the hell
of it i mean
i can't say i'm against it uh what do
you mean for the hell of it it's for the
memes
that's the best reason i've ever heard
yeah just bring some fun and positivity
yeah yeah i totally agree next up every
billboard in the world
is pewdiepie can we do it guys hey i'll
buy a billboard
you can buy football and we have all the
billboards all right
yeah okay let's do it yeah
i swear every time pewdiepie grows a
beard he descends a little further into
insanity
what do you mean i'm 31.
whoever drew this should get a youtube
channel
thanks guys maybe i'll do pewdiepie arts
and crafts
since you guys liked it so much i could
make 55
yeah i'll i'll give away all the coins
that's a good idea i should have done
that i should have given back the coins
into the pewdiepie economy right here
since i'm rich
now right i can just give away
you got to do uh you got a pumpkin
because you asked for stuff already yeah
this one this one definitely gets a fat
one
lizard made me smile award oh this one
gets a big peepee
i like that one oh god damn i'm already
broke are you serious
there we go cool i'll do a couple more
because this is fun
girls during puberty oh my god i hate
everything guys during puberty
nah nah nah no more
no blood marks that gets car licensed
marcie
marshall getting ready to make new toys
actually i'm the one that
this is so shameful to admit
i'm the one that has to mutilate
all the barbies i have to saw them for
her and it feels very uncomfortable i'm
not going to lie
sawing through a barbie and undressing
her beards finally plays among us with
mr bees they're getting posted together
i miss the stream
they both make videos about it hell yeah
who's saying that he didn't get any
birthday wishes me who posted two
birthday wishes which i didn't knew
yeah all right well thank you there it
is
[Laughter]
with that stance i'm mugging you throw
back to when i watch
the why at the same time while i work at
what
hell yeah amazing i should have thought
of that because i read that i would set
them up for halloween
honestly that has really put me in a
great mood i really appreciate all the
memes it's really fun
i love i love this community so proud of
this community
thank you for watching what's that graph
meme
uh 18.9 of you aren't subscribed
subscribe it's free all right edo
breakfast
[Music]
you